Шановні колеги безпекова ситуація в
херсонському регіоні значно деградує
ворог якого героїчна українська армія
вибила з Херсону мститься і щодня
обстрілює житлові цивільні квартали
цього героїчного міста і тому для нас
дуже важливо щоб надавати підтримку
військовий сьогодні тим силам які
боронять Херсонський напрямок але й
призначати адекватну владу ми тільки
повернулися з Херсону і були абсолютно
вражені тим що керівниця військова
адміністрації міста пані Лугова вона
абсолютно неадекватна сьогодні
представляє українську владу Вибачте в
місті де залишається більше 60 000
населення де сьогодні немає роботи де
немає виплат тому що немає роботи де
поки не запроваджені виплати
дуже гарних міжнародних організацій бо
тільки збираються ці реєстри волонтери
вирішили створити волонтерську пекарню
Яке ж було по дивування громади яка
потребує сьогодні
свіжого А іноді Немає коштів це купити
коли пані керівничка просто заборонила
працювати ці пекарні з незрозумілих
причин так само є скарги сьогодні від
громадських організацій щодо відсутності
діалогу пані
керівниці військової адміністрації щодо
непрозоро розподілу гуманітарної
допомоги яка надходить від організації
на нашу думку
рішення ганьблять і центральну владу
адже хтось у цих керівничок призначає
тому звичайно
одруження але ми просимо всіх причетних
до формування кадрового СРСР резерву а
мова йде про банкову призначати людей не
лояльних на тих хто будуть міньйонами
банкової а адекватних професійних е-е
мужніх
відповідними і таких які будуть Керу
ватись захистом
захистом здорового глузду а не знаєте
якимись дивним